Hello,
and welcome to today's session.
Today, we are taking a look at Cilium,
a CNI implementation for Kubernetes.
And I am very fortunate to be joined
by Ilya here, who is a member of
the team at ISO Valiant, who are the
creators and maintainers
of Cilium. Hello, Ilya. How are you? Hi,
David. How are you doing? I'm rather quite
well.
I'm doing very well as well. Thank you
very much. A lovely autumn day here in
London.
Well, yeah. It's getting pretty cold up here
in Scotland too, actually. I think this is
the coldest day we've had yet. Like, I'm
actually I'm gonna put the heating back on
soon. That's where we're getting to now. That's
right. Yeah. Yeah.
So
I think we're gonna break the formula a
little bit today
because
I had done a little bit of preparation,
which means I have used the cluster API
to spin up a Kubernetes cluster.
However, it's currently in a pending state because
a cluster cannot become ready until it has
a CNI implementation.
So what I wanna do is we'll jump
straight in to deploy and install Cilium.
And then we'll jump back and we'll have
a little bit of a conversation around what
Cilium is, why it exists, etcetera. You alright
with that plan? Sounds good to me.
Awesome.
Alright. So
that means we need my screen like so.
There we go.
And we pop over here. So as you
can see, I have run
cube control
passing on the special cluster API cube config.
I've ran get nodes and you can see
we're still in our not ready state.
So that means I have to install Cilium.
Mhmm.
But I assume that if I ask you
how to do that, you're gonna tell me
to go to the documentation. So That's right.
There
may be a guide for for Packet that
you could have a look at.
So I would say this is a self
managed Kubernetes. So. You
can see I've clicked on a few links
already.
I think I did. Yeah.
And then managed etcd.
Alright.
So do you recommend Helm? Do you recommend
something else?
Yeah. So I think you could either go
with Helm or Quickstart.
Quickstart is basically just the the default kinda
Helm setup.
So it's just like the Helm chart rendered
with Helm template.
So, yeah, I think using Helm is fine.
I don't think you wanna be on the
manage that CD page.
No? Yeah. You wanna go to quick start.
I think quick installation. Yeah. Gotcha. Okay. And
I think there are two options. There is
a flat manifest and there's a helm option
from what I remember. There's just a flat
manifest. Is there a helm option down below?
No. Look like. Okay. Fine. Let's just try
that. That that that should just work.
Just work.
That's my favorite sentence.
That's the purpose of this
flat manifest that it just has all the
defaults.
Alright. So we have a service account. We
have a config map. We some r back
configuration.
We've got a daemon set and a deployment.
Oh, a Cilium operator as well. It's it's
Cilium. Yeah. And it goes into the cube
system namespace normally like this.
Alright. I guess we should validate.
Yeah.
I I like this actually. I hadn't noticed
this previously, but copy first line instead of
copy all. That's pretty sweet. I like that.
Goodness. Yeah.
Alright. So this runs a cube system get
pods.
Oh, no. We got a crash lit.
Hey. Let's have a look. It will probably
tell us what I mean, it should tell
us what what is happening. Is it just
because the operator is not ready yet?
No. No. Yeah.
The operator is not required for
for Cilium to start.
Alright. Let's take a look at some
Yeah. I've not run Cilium on a packet.
So, you know, it's a thing.
Okay. So it's in the initialization.
Oh, I'm not passing. Oh, I just deployed
that to the wrong cluster.
Oh, have you? Deployed that to Docker for
Mac. Oh, that's why it's crashing. Okay. Yeah.
It does crash on Docker for Mac.
Sorry.
Okay. So we need my special cube config.
Copy. Quick start dot cube config.
Is it
intentional
dot company?
Or is it Oh, no. It's it's definitely
just me.
Generally, when things go wrong, it's always my
fault. So
it would now install it to the correct
cluster.
And so we now need to go for
the cube system namespace and get pods. Right?
You need a you need, like, a speech
bubble there, David.
It's always my fault.
It's always my fault. Yeah. Okay. Goes wrong.
That's looking better. Right? That says running now.
Not healthy, but running. That's progress. Oh, sweet.
Yeah. Sweet.
Which should stop.
I'm sorry to worry. Sorry. No worries.
So if you if you look at the
logs of one of the Cilium parts, just
to verify that,
it is truly happy.
K. Let's grab
one here.
Yep. I mean Yeah. I'm assuming that looks
alright. So I can now run that Yeah.
Yeah. Validate one. Right? Yeah. That's right. Yeah.
So there's I we did that. Okay. Yeah.
The connectivity test.
Oh, that one. Alright.
Okay. So this is applying a manifest?
That's right. And it's just, like, a bunch
of pods that that try to talk to
each other.
So there's like a an echo server and
and
some crawl based
readiness probes.
Alright. I'll trust you. Let's let's just copy
and paste.
Only I'll remember. But I should just export
that environment variable for my cube config, shouldn't
I? I'll do it after.
Does that apply?
Alright.
Oh, no. Dot cube config.
And that's gonna get annoying quickly, so let's
let's apply.
And then oh, it creates a lot. Alright.
And then export
cube config.
There. I've I've got it in my history
already. Okay. Nice.
So let's just run
get pods, correct cluster. Good. I'm happy. Mhmm.
And this is keep system there. Right? So
if you do get pods minus a,
capital a
yeah.
So the default namespace now has those
connectivity test pods.
So we can see that they're still creating.
Alright. Let's just run a rewatch.
Yep.
So I guess that's just pulling images right
now. I'm gonna assume this is
hopefully quickly gonna start parallel.
Yeah. Yeah. I think it's fairly quick. Time
to drink coffee.
There we go. There's one.
Alright. So we got
so this connectivity test is
is it testing network policies based on some
of these names?
It just
it just
test connectivity
within the cluster and
and outbound.
Yeah. Because I see pod to it denied
CNP.
Yeah. I think I think there's there's one
policy tested that's
CNP is a Cilium network policy.
And
and most of them are, you know, pods
on different nodes, pods on the same node,
pods to Google, pods to some other
fairly reliable
Internet addresses.
Alright. So can
I'm gonna do one thing,
and that's just confirm that these are not
stuck pending.
Yep. Let's just check that then. Anything, and
then we can I I actually do the
the conversational part where we talk about Cilium?
So
so let's just describe that pod.
Oh.
Post IPAM failure range is full.
Okay.
So let's have a look at
Cilium pods.
Okay.
Yeah. Okay. So they're running.
Operator is also running.
Do you want some logs from from what
does the setter mean? Can we start with
that? What does that mean if it's unable
to allocate IP via local Cilium agent?
Range is full.
Right. So
well, this is, you know, one of the
so there are multiple different
IPAM modes
in Cilium.
And
the quick start
picks the default
IPAM mode, which I'm just going to double
check now.
Or you can double check it, actually. If
you if you
if you grab that
Cilium quick start manifest.
Yeah. This one here. Right? Yeah.
Yeah.
So if you look for
IPAM
The pool? Cluster pool.
Okay.
Yeah. I think that has certain implications.
Like,
if you look in Cilium docs, the IPAM
section,
I think, basically, we just need something else
for
it's not so much packet, actually. It would
be cluster API.
IPAM.
Your
Azure page for some reason?
I'll
just click on documentation.
I just Yeah. This go away. Didn't find
anything for iPads.
Oh,
okay.
So
Yeah.
Yeah. I would say that. I would say
that. I'm
not sure.
Advanced networking, maybe?
I've done cluster pool. So okay. I'm just
looking at the documentation
for cluster pool.
So we can
check that. Let me So I've I've got
two IPAM modes here in the docs. CRD
backed IPAM or CRD backed Cilium cluster pool
IPAM.
Yeah. So let's have a look at
cluster pool
because that appears to be the one that
we are currently using.
Oh, yes. So, yeah, we need to check
cluster pool IP before pod CIDR.
So if you look back at the
at that manifest
Mhmm.
What do we have here? Cluster pull I
p v four CIDR.
If you just go back to where I
found was.
So it's 10
slash eight.
Okay.
And then p four mask size 24.
Okay. Well, that's well, this should work
unless you think this might challenge.
That's clashing with the packet private network. Oh,
okay. So if you
if you basically grab this manifest
and store it locally
and then
We'll make some changes. Yeah.
I think we impromptu debug hackathon. So That's
right.
So if I search for IPAM,
we're just gonna change this to be
68.
Yeah.
Yeah. We're alright with that? Yeah. And two
slash 24 for the nodes is just fine.
So the second parameter is how much a
node gets. So this is good.
Alright. So do I need to uninstall or
can I apply this over the top? Up
apply and restart Cilium manifests
Cilium pods.
K. So I can do a Cube apply
Cilium.
Yeah.
Yeah. This is fine.
And then you want me to delete and
restart those? Yeah.
Alright. So cube system, delete pods. Can I
do a label side? Yeah. So Kate's up.
Cilium.
Yeah. Yeah.
Nice.
And I
forgot if Cilium operator had the same label
or not, but
I think
you might want to to, yeah, to kick
Cilium operator as well.
Maybe.
Yeah.
I just believe it's two. Yeah. There's just
two of them.
Alright.
So in theory, give that a minute, and
we should
potentially see some other ones here spanging up
as the IPAM IPAM error goes away.
Yep.
Let's see how Cilium looks.
Alright. Let's
just pull down some logs.
I think this seriously works now.
See that?
Yeah.
Let's let's have a look at the at
the connectivity test pods.
I think they started coming up. Okay.
No? Still still failing?
They might just need to check as well,
actually. They could be
Oh, yeah. They could be still It's just
kind of a limbo as it were.
We'll delete the echoes and we'll see Mhmm.
If that little nudge helps.
No. They're not describing that.
Well Still the same error.
As we could always uninstall Cilium and
Mhmm.
Reinstall.
Yeah. So we're still getting the same IPAM
ranges full. How can we confirm that change
took place?
Yeah.
So we can
yeah. That's that's a good question.
I think if you exact into this one
of the Cilium parts.
Yep.
Grab this one.
And you can run
you could just run Cilium
command.
Yep. And it has a bunch of
things. Yes. For example okay.
For example, take a look at node.
Cilium status, actually.
What are we saying?
This 10 seems to still be here.
That's
And this.
I okay. Right.
So that's And there's there's a config map
mounted in the Cilium pod.
If you look at mounts
I forgot what it was, but there's a
there's config map mount.
Yeah. That's a TMP sitting config map.
Yep.
And what does
yeah. IPAM is still cluster pool cluster pool
IP before CIDR.
Okay.
Let's just delete
on the entire thing, and and then we'll
just put it back up and see what
happens.
Okay. So let's confirm.
Quite over yet. Mhmm. Give it a minute.
I wish you have to tell a joke.
I don't have any jokes today.
I I did hear good news. You probably
saw my tweet, but not necessarily all of
our
the the attendance watched
saw that tweet. And the they they they
found that dogs can detect coronavirus.
Oh, wow. Dogs detecting coronavirus.
Sounds pretty cool. I mean, can you imagine,
like,
basically,
within ten seconds, they can tell.
Wow.
Yeah.
I'm impressed.
Yep.
I'm I'm pretty sure in the past, I've
read or or seen a story about dogs
able to detect cancer as well and even
Parkinson's.
Wow.
So I'm I mean, I guess I'm not
entirely surprised,
but still astounded.
Okay. So let's
see if Cilium is back up and running.
Not yet.
There's some parts that are pending.
And I'll what I'll do is I'm gonna
grab this network connectivity check.
Fail.
Okay. And delete
that those pods and then just redeploy them
again. I wanna give it the best opportunity
I can. Mhmm.
Where was that quick start guide? There we
go. Yeah.
Self managed, quick installations, scroll down the bottom.
We want this one here.
So I can do a key delete. Mhmm.
I've got a QPS detail command.
They're all gone. Now
should we confirm the IPAM range again? Or
are you confident if I just apply
this that we make it a bit further
forward?
Well, let's let's let's double check. Let's just,
like, play safe.
Alright. So you wanna exec into one of
the Cilium pods. Yep. Keep system l, Kate's
Epsilon.
Oh, yeah.
Yep. And bash.
I can then go to cam cilium
and cluster poo I p four cider.
Alright. I mean, that Okay. That's that's good.
And cilium status?
Oh.
Yeah. That's
Maybe maybe it reads this from
from also okay. Well,
I have a suggestion from my colleague here,
one option that we could try.
Okay. But could you could you also just
list files in this config map real quick?
Yeah.
Is there
Enable PPO.
Uh-huh. Let's check here. I'm
just looking out for a native
native routing cider. It's not here. Shall we
shall we switch to Helm now? Because, clearly,
quick start
doesn't work in this.
So quick start definitely works on Minikube, for
example,
as is without any modifications. But,
clearly, here,
we we'd we'd benefit from using Helm now.
This Helm has all the all the options,
and the suggestion that my colleague just made
refers to a Helm
value.
Alright.
So
delete
delete.
Okay. We're now c and I list once
more. Mhmm. So
we're gonna deploy with
help.
Yeah. So, yeah, if you go for
yeah. If you just with manage that CD,
I guess.
Right.
So but you don't you just, yeah, just
don't use those as CD flags, basically. Just
you don't care about those. You said version
and namespace, and then and then any values
that
you might wanna specify.
And I think we'd be looking to
use
Oh, I guess we should grab the default
values. Right? That's right. Yeah.
Let's just make sure I'm in the right
place.
Yeah.
Oh, there's no values there.
Alright. I guess I can just Yep.
Download it.
Oh, wait. The values file would be in
the in the repo, maybe. Yeah. So if
you go to the
I mean, default values will
will be there anyway. So
but what I would
suggest is that
Search for helm
now.
Should I just use minikip?
Oh, we could we could run it on
minikip first. Yeah. Of course. I think it
is possible that the cluster API setup will
need a little bit more work.
Alright. Hopefully, that won't take too long. That
should just take
oh, do I need to destroy my old
mini cube and pass in some sort of
flag for this CNI or just apply some
Good question. I think, Keith, you might want
to
I'm not entirely sure if mini cube
enables CNI mode by default at the moment.
As in it didn't used to do that,
but maybe that had changed.
Let's take a look at the option. Also,
you wanna unexplored onset your cube config. Right?
Okay. Let's see what we got here.
CNA.
Yeah. Okay. So I can just do dash
dash c and I equals Cilium. You can
do that.
And if it's an old version, we can
upgrade.
So I guess it's important to note here
then that those the issues with the quick
start YAML is just with the cluster API,
and that's not something that people should really
expect to happen
on another cluster.
Well, I was a little bit hopeful in
suggesting that.
I should make it work. It'd be nice
to to have a blog post about that.
Oh, yeah. We we we can we'll have
that later.
Mhmm. So this
Oh, there we go. Okay. So Cilium is
now just spinning up. So that's happening. Oh,
sweet. Do you wanna check what version are
we getting there?
It just described that part or whatever.
Describe
part 70 m b.
Yep. Looks good. I'll grab
Mitch.
I took the scraper. No. Okay.
Yeah. Of course.
Okay.
Image. Image. Image.
We got one eight zero.
Okay. Yeah. We can, you know, we can
do a minor upgrade on that, but
not not necessary for for the purpose of
the demo anyway.
Alright. I think we're good. I think we've
we've got a little bit installed on our
ManyKube cluster. Sweet.
So you wanna install the connectivity check?
Yes. It should still be
nope. Okay. I'll grab that URL again.
That's the quick start.
Connectivity.
Oh, that was over here.
So question to you. Like, does does the
cluster API provider for Pocket support any of
the CNIs with, like, just, you know,
network name or whatever?
Like, by specifying you could can you specify
a name of a network and get it
set up?
I'm not entirely sure, to be honest.
Yeah. I'm not sure.
I
I just I I wonder if this is
a packet specific thing. The fact that it
was pulling out that ten zero six makes
me think that
something's going on there. I mean, I'll look
into that after this session. Yeah. Of course.
Yeah. At least probably I'll write about it
for sure because I'm definitely my my interest
is I'm very curious. My interest is peak.
So
this is much better now. It's running through
all of these tests. Sweet.
I guess that's a good thing that we've
not got anything and I crashed it back
off or any other That's looking good to
me. Yeah.
Yeah. Some of these take a little while
to stabilize. So yeah.
Alright. So should we talk about Cilium just
now then? Yeah. Absolutely. Yeah. Yeah. We got
a little bit distracted there, but we are
Okay. So
why don't we start with
just,
you know, the the CNI and what that
means for Kubernetes and people using Kubernetes?
Yes. What is the container networking interface?
Yeah. I mean, there are many
many things I could say about it, but
I just remember starting with Kubernetes back in
the day when
like, it was my first
Kubernetes related project to make BeavNet at the
time work with Kubernetes.
And and that basically required to install it
required me to install Kubernetes in a certain
manner.
And that
well, basically, you just had to make
Docker networking somehow work for Kubernetes.
You know, basically, you had to configure Docker
bridge in a particular way, and then Kubernetes
would just leverage that.
But that didn't give you enough flexibility,
and that
was sort of
implicit rather than explicit. You kind of implicitly
configured the underlying infrastructure to to do certain
things with regards to networking.
The Kubernetes had zero
knowledge of what is going on there.
So that, you know, sort of worked for
the early days of Kubernetes, but then the
docker plug ins proposal had been floated,
the
lead network plug ins.
And that
had challenges when when we tried to that
that API had challenges when we tried to
integrate it with Kubernetes.
It required, essentially, its own k v store.
It was designed for Docker Swarm
Alright. And Docker Swarm's k v store
effectively.
And
it's just a very rough summary. If anybody
is hearing this and want to correct me,
please feel feel free to tweet at me.
But this is a very rough summary of
the
of the history
on this matter. And the CNI proposal had
been floated by
folks from CoreOS.
And and
then, you know, it got actually adopted by
the the the wider Kubernetes community,
and
now all network
plugins for Kubernetes implement CNI.
And that's the way to interact with
you know, it's it's like it's the interface
between Cubelet and the the network plug in.
So I guess what's important for people then
to understand here is that the CNI gives
them the flexibility, the option, the choice, whatever
their you know, whatever's driving them to pick
a CNI implementation. And, clearly, they can swap
them out as they wish
to any them. Yeah.
It's it's a little bit challenging at present
to swap out a network in a
in a live cluster. So migration
is
is still a
the kind of one of the less mature
features of of the the
CNI
spec.
And, you know, it's like CNI is often
easy when that's, I guess, one of my
main challenges. When you say CNI,
I'm thinking of the of the actual spec
of the container network interface that that I
referred to. But people use it much more
broadly. And I think you were actually
hoping that I'll tell you something a bit
more broad than that.
And that that's that's kind of a problem,
I guess, that people who've been around for
a while have with some of this terminology.
Anyway, what I'm trying to what I'm trying
to say is that
more most people actually refer to CNI as
a a network implementation for Kubernetes
and not the interface that that I seem
to think about every time you mention it.
Yeah. That that's too scary for me to
try and understand the interface that I've been
to. I've been so distanced from it. I
mean, I I didn't my knowledge of it
is purely as a consumer and not as
a contributor or That's right. Yeah. So
a
you know, so Cilium is one of the
network implementations. It does implement the CNI interface,
and you can install it in pretty much
any Kubernetes cluster.
You may need to tweak parameters as we
just saw earlier for request API provider.
The
main advantage of Cilium is that it relies
on the latest and greatest
kernel based technology where
where essentially Cilium hooks directly into the kernel
using eBPF,
which is the kernel extension mechanism, effectively.
One of ways I can describe eBPF is
that, basically, with eBPF, you can
reimplement the entire TCP IP stack if you
really wish to.
So, you know,
that that enables you to do a lot.
That enables you to optimize a lot of
things. Right?
So
for example, one of very cool optimizations that
Cilium offers
is that when
Istio
when pods that are running on Istio are
talking to to to their sidecars on local
host, that doesn't have to hit the the
bottom of the stack.
We
essentially short circuit
the communication
of local host to local host,
improving system Istio performance dramatically.
I don't have figures of hand, but that's
just one of the examples that I think
illustrates pretty well what what sort of things
that Cilium can do.
Okay. That that that makes sense to me.
Yeah. I mean, I guess it's some of
it. Sorry. Anya, go ahead. Some of the
other major
elements are like,
instead of relying on
IP tables
or something like IPVS for load balancing of
services
inside a cluster,
essentially,
we can replace Kube proxy with eBPF
based implementation as well.
Ah, very cool. Which effectively eliminates
any any use of IP tables.
Well, I mean, as a former SRE has
had to has had to deal with IP
tables and contract over my my lifetime of
administration, I'm happy to see the back of
IP tables if that is an option. So
Yeah. That's right. And one one of the
one of the the challenges that that IP
tables has
at scale is that it just doesn't perform
too well
Yeah. For sure. When you're when you're doing
network policy
or or when you're doing
a load balancing in a large Kubernetes cluster.
Okay. So would you say that,
you know, all not all CNI implementations are
alike. Right? I mean, they all have a
similar API surface that they conform to, but
Cilium offers stuff above and beyond that. It
gives people That's right. Like, those performance benefits
you were just talking about. Yeah. That's right.
And Cilium does
get a little bit into this
the service mesh territory
by integrating with Istio, but also so on
its own, we have, for example,
layer seven policies. So you could you could
you could define policies on, like, HTTP
level.
So you could, for example, deny certain requests
unless they contain a particular header.
Right. Okay. I think I understand that. So
that's would you say that this the secret
sauce of Cilium then is eBPF? Is that
what's really allowing for all of these unique
features to exist? Is that integration
really tight integration with the with the kernel?
Right. Absolutely.
Okay. Excellent.
Well, I think we're in a position let
me pop this back up on the screen.
Oh,
nope. That one. There we go.
I think all of those tests have run
except for one.
Oh, we still got a few pending.
You know, you'd actually take a while. So
will we just start playing with this
and remove the connectivity test? Are you comfortable
with that? Sure. Yeah. Sure.
Alright. Yeah. Look, you know, some of these
will be pending because it's a single node
cluster, David. Oh, yeah. Of course. Yeah. I
mean, we're running on many no. We don't
have access to, like, that worker pool. There's
a whole bunch of constraints there.
That's right. Because because these tests are testing
node to node communication as well.
Oh,
but that would explain why these multi node
and the node ones are probably never gonna
be quite happy. So I can do delete
pods
all,
and I should only Oh, they'll come back.
No. You you you
just want to delete the pods. Yeah. Yeah.
These are deployments. Okay. Yeah. Didn't notice the
the triple. Delete deployments all.
Delete deployment.
Alright.
Boom.
So let me pop open an error. I'm
assuming we're gonna need some YAML here. So
For sure. We probably want something running on
our cluster in order to play with it.
So there's a there's there's the
there's a Star Wars demo if you like.
Oh, nice. Okay.
And how do I find the Star Wars
demo?
See if you scroll down. I think the
yeah. If you go to next.
Okay. No. It takes you to that was,
like
A tutorial?
Maybe. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. For example.
Yeah.
So identity aware,
lock in, like Yeah. No. For example, identity
aware, HTTP aware policy enforcement. That sounds fun.
So this is as mini cube. Right? This
is mini cube. Yep. Yeah. And if you
just scroll down,
this will deploy
this will tell you how to deploy the
Star Wars demo.
I can see references to that already.
Do I need to do this e d
PDF, man? No. No. No. That that's that
that's I'm assuming that's out of date, actually.
So
Alright. So we're gonna take this first lane
here, which deploys
the Star Wars app. Okay. Cool.
And there is a warning here at the
top. What I'm gonna do is apply that
YAML, and then it tells me that if
I haven't read the introduction to Cilium and
Hubble yet, you would encourage that. So I
don't know what Hubble is. So maybe you
could answer that question for us. Oh, yeah.
Absolutely.
We should probably install Hubble, actually.
You see, we should have used the
Helm chart that enables us to do more
Humble as well.
Anyway so,
yeah, Hubble offers visibility
into
network flows inside of your cluster
and visibility
into,
you know, for example,
policy verdicts
and
and some such things. So you can you
can actually see what what is going on
and when policies apply and
other such things. It has a CLI and
a UI.
We can get to using Hubble later on.
Let's let's let's try the
Star Wars demo.
Yeah. I think this would be in default
namespace.
Yep. It looks like we've got two desktops,
one type error, and an x wing running
in our cluster.
Cool. And there are probably some services as
well?
Yeah. Okay. Yep. We still have the connectivity
desk. We have the desktop service.
Okay. Can you can you reach the the
Death Star service or pull forward it?
Can.
I I get really weird with things lying
around that shouldn't be there. Yeah. I know.
Right. Okay. So we wanna port forward the
SBC to the Death Star.
Mhmm.
On port eighty eight eighty eight.
So this must be a web service.
Yeah. Is that correct?
Yeah.
I think you could try slash v one.
Yeah. Right. It has a few endpoints. Yep.
Cool.
Alright. So if you go back to the
to the tutorial
Oh, I cannot I was
navigating looking for the whole Of
course. We'll go back.
There we go. Right. Sorry. I won't touch
anything else until I That's fine. Thought you
tell me.
Okay. So we did this step here. We've
confirmed the parts of service.
And we can take a look at the
Cilium endpoints.
Yeah. Or
you could you could just do
you yeah. You can just do
Kukulo get
CEB
for Cilium endpoint.
Okay. So get Cilium
endpoints.
All All namespaces,
I suppose.
Don't matter.
I wonder why.
Okay. If you exec into one of the
Cilium pods and do what the,
no, the the command above
Oh. It did an exec into the the
Cilium pod and did Cilium endpoint Okay.
So keep system get pods
at
IT
Cilium v bash Cilium
endpoint.
Okay.
So
this is
okay.
So, well, it doesn't actually look like
it looks like something isn't working actually,
because we should see the
the pods from
from default namespace here.
Can you do list dash
help?
Yep.
Jason now has
okay. So it actually
So can you help me understand what's happened
here? We have deployed some pods. Now it's
Yeah. So for for each of for each
of the pods, Cilium creates
an endpoint object.
So it creates an identity for each of
the pod.
So and the the step in the
in the tutorial is to confirm that we
have these identities.
And, clearly, we don't we don't have them
here right now. I think it is possible.
Unfortunately, suspecting that
Minicube installed Cilium,
but some configuration is missing.
I wonder if that was because my Minicube
was kind of existing. So I'm gonna feel
brave and restart
it and redeploy all of that stuff within
a blink of an eye.
Alright.
Yeah. We can we can chat more about
e b p f and
other cool tech.
So I'm assuming I mean, maybe I should
have copied that command from the actual quick
start, but I think c n I c
m should be it. And So that that
that, you know, that brings about one of
the challenges that that I mentioned earlier, that
installing,
any network into an existing cluster
is a tricky business.
Yeah. It's not something that you know, most
most normal customers are not gonna be messing
around with their CNI implementation once it's up
and working. That's Right. You know,
my crazy attitude. So
let's make sure Cilium is
It is, however, something that that that has
been done. There was actually a blog post
recently where somebody migrated.
Was it Monza? I I thought it was
Sky Bet.
JetStack wrote the blog post. Oh, there must
be more than one then. There was a
talk at cube con from the Monzo team
where
they were talking about doing a live migration
of their CNI implementation.
I can't remember what they're room for. I
think they moved away from Flanagan into Calico,
and they did that live without any downtime,
which was pretty impressive.
Yes. So that that was one more more
recent, like, couple of weeks ago, blog post
that documented
migration
from I don't remember which provider to Cilium.
They didn't if it it is, a multi
step downs
or shall I say many step downs.
So I'm trying to work out why my
core DNS has decided it gonna run there.
I am having the worst luck with my
cluster today.
Uh-oh.
A minus n cube system
describe
pod.
Yeah. That's broken.
It's a commonality
of errors today.
Okay.
Maybe
which
sorry. Can you can you show me the
output of the
of Minicube when you started it up? Yeah.
Of course. So
it said something about Docker driver, and I
wasn't entirely sure what that means.
Oh, yeah. My Minikube runs on Docker for
Mac. Is that a problem?
Oh.
Why not kind? Kind actually works.
But that runs in Docker for Mac too.
Right? Yeah. But we we we we had
a guide for that. Okay.
Well, let's
yeah.
Let's do do you have some
you have some hypervisor available?
I'm thinking
I I have no idea.
I forgot many.
We
do have access to this.
You know what? There's a there's a kind
there's a
yeah. We can try and fix that one.
Okay.
So
so tell me tell me a little bit
about this.
This is using IP before four addresses
in the one four seven range on the
host side. Right? So that's the public IP
addresses. Every pop over here, it got the
the private oh, sorry. So, yeah. It took
a 1080. So 1080. Yeah. Okay. Oh, can
you can you show me your cluster API
configs?
That I can do.
Yeah. That'd be handy.
Yep. Dot the m o s. So
that specifies some CIDRs initially. Right?
It does. Yes. So if I pull up.
Yeah.
So pod CIDR is is that. So
and service CIDR is 172.
So
what we can do is
just just reuse this when we
when we configure Cilium.
I thought we did use 1921680016.
I pull up the Cilium.YAML
here. Yeah. But let's let's just use the
Helm
chart instead. Right? Okay. Let's let's take a
look at that then. So
Yeah. Let me just give you the exact
command, actually,
because I think I I have something handy
that
that might just might just work. So
it would be
well,
can use Helm template, I guess.
Is there a chat window in this? Yeah.
On the right hand side, there's private chat.
Feel free to drop it in there. Oh,
we actually have a few comments.
So you
oh, yeah.
So if you try this
let me just drop some of the things
that are unrelated.
Cluster pool so we can have a fairly
explicit configuration.
And did you say it's 19268Dot0Dot0Slash16.
Dot 6 8
Slash 16. Yep.
So and we're gonna do that
for
cluster pool a p v four
and the native routing slider.
Yeah. And then,
yes, we can keep the p of
Yeah. And
global endpoint routes too.
Okay. Let's try this, and I think this
is gonna be a good starting point.
Mhmm. Awesome thing. I don't know about formatting.
You might have to fix it up.
Alright. So I already run this. Yeah. Cool.
So I should be able to do this
template. It should Yeah. Well, you wanna get
rid of the backslashes or or insert. Yeah.
Yep. Yeah. Yeah. Good idea to save that
in a in a little file.
Yep.
We'll call this Helm template s h.
That's that's our YAML. So we'll call this
Cilium
Helm dot YAML.
And And do you have something in this
do you still have Cilium in the cube
system namespace?
So let's reexport our cube config. Let's get
our pods.
Are you in the same directory?
Yes.
I
can do this manually. So kubect config.
Why
is it speaking to one two seven?
Oh,
you know what? Your mini cube has updated
your
copy click start cube config.
Did it?
I suspect. Let's have a look. Oh, no.
I'm I'm
please don't have done that.
Oh, we can get it again. Hold on.
So I need to
to CTL.
Let's just do it this way.
Woah. It's a lot of stuff.
Alright.
So there is a there
is a guide here, and this has the
command I need, which goes into my management
cluster and gets me my KubeConfig.
We will write this back to that directory.
I am on the wrong
cluster. Oh, because I'm on Munich.
I'm a major disaster.
Alright.
So let's change the context,
docker desktop.
Now I can get my
I don't know how you hit me.
How many classes do you have, David?
One to a few, it would appear.
I use
I'm gonna just drop this shell.
Let's
I I think it's just confused.
Yeah. It is just confused.
Cool. Yeah. Yeah. Really?
So which means I should now be able
to get my
Your copy
configuration.
Yeah. Like,
keep config. Yeah. Which is now my copy
config. I'm gonna reexport this. I'm gonna then
do get pods.
Right. That
Oh, yeah. And we have no Cilium. We're
currently in the c and I free zone.
How did we get back there? Oh, did
you delete it from the previous attempt, or
is this is your backup cluster?
No. This is the first cluster we were
playing with, and we deleted the Cilium implementation.
And I would just just confirm.
Yeah. Yeah. Right? So this is a If
you yeah. So if you if you do
Cube Cuddle create an s Cilium.
Yeah. Sweet. And now
try that Helm template command.
Yeah. You already did that, so just apply
that. And now
check pods in the Cilium namespace.
Right.
That looks good.
Yep.
Okay. Are we gonna brave the connectivity test
again? So
if you if you if you if you
pop into one of the Cilium pods, and
let's just check Cilium status.
Okay. So we want Cilium
exec. I should have given you this command
there now. I'm sure it's gonna work now.
Cilium
oh, IT.
Yeah. Okay.
Means I wanna run Cilium Health status. Was
that right? No? Oh, just status. Status. Woo.
I think it's looking good.
Endpoints unreachable.
Maybe that's I just know that. The
the IPAM part looks looks good. It does
look good. Yes. Yes, man. Yeah. We're getting
there.
Alright. So now the connectivity check.
Let's deploy that to
to the default namespace again.
This one.
Yes. Is this fish?
No. Z Shell with a lot of plugins.
A lot of plugins.
I like mine without any.
Cool.
Yeah. It looks like
so if you do now
k. Get c p
in the default namespace.
There should be some sentiment points there.
No. Not yet. Okay.
This is also kinda
Oh, no. Again, really. Is this a is
this a new one?
13 seconds. Yeah. It looks like. Okay. Yes.
This is a new one.
Yeah. It says the range
is full.
Yeah. I don't get why that happens.
Okay.
Let's
back in here. So Mhmm. When I'm when
I'm working with Cilium and we have problems
like this, right, we have the Cilium CLI.
What what can I do with the Cilium
CLI?
We can have a look at Cilium status
once again.
So it is complaining about anything.
Doesn't look like. It looks healthy.
Looks like it's using the I don't know.
So
what does it mean?
So the node is reachable. This is the
private IPs of the node. That seems
cool, but it can't
because I have one of eight reachable. Does
this mean the Cilium agents aren't able to
speak to one another?
Oh,
do you have any security groups in there
or anything like that?
No. The these are these can these
can all pretty much reach each other. There
shouldn't be
So yeah. So, basically, between nodes, all ports
are open That's correct. As far as bucket
is concerned. Okay. So inside the Cilium pod,
you could also run
Cilium
health.
yeah. I think there's Cilium dash health, actually.
There's a separate command, Cilium dash health.
David
dash health. Just sitting in dash health.
Sorry.
Alright. There we go. Status.
Okay. So we got a couple of written
to host issues here.
So the ICMP stack is fine. HTTP is
fine. And then the so what is endpoint
connectivity?
Where is this 1000214
coming from? Because that's not gonna work on
the packet.
Yeah. I wonder why this is what we
are seeing here once again.
So
this
this would be
a node IP.
I guess, can you do get nodes?
You mean control get notes. Right? Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. All wide.
Yeah.
No.
10 Can we can we change?
I mean, I'm assuming this endpoint subnetsider
is coming from the Cilium configuration. Can we
override that to not be 10? So this
is okay. So that's
oh, these are these are pods that are
that had been running before Cilium was installed.
Right?
So can you can you do get pod
pods in cube system
or wide as well?
Yeah.
So
but that that at CD pod, what about
it? Can you show it to me?
Is this is that at CD pod showing
up here?
Hold on. Let me just do a chip
system get pods.
Yeah. Okay. HCD copy. Yeah. And chip system
get pods all wide.
Yeah. Okay. Alright. The one is
here.
Oh, yeah. Where is this?
Yeah. What are all those IPs now?
What's the what what's the
+1 080? 1 4 7 is public, basically.
Is that the case?
And +1 0801080
is your private one. Right? Yeah. +1 080
is our private network. 147 is our public
network. So you you so you basically have
private node public nodes and private
control point.
Is that
Yes.
Okay. Cool.
Yeah.
So
it's trying to hit the
and I guess
yeah. So you are saying that wouldn't work
on the packet network because of
Oh, so when I said that, my concern
was the let me just exit back into
the computer.
When we ran
the health cluster,
this endpoint coming pivot to 1002254,
I mean, packet's not gonna let you hit
the TCP stack on its private network range
without blocking traffic because it'll think you're trying
to jump over to other projects or to
other
machines that aren't under your ownership. I assume
this endpoint connectivity cider is something that Cilium
is creating within the cluster,
which I thought may have been causing confusing.
But that was me speculating, to be honest.
It's it's actually it's like all Cilium pods
want to talk to one another on port
4240.
So they're just pinging one another on those
ports. But how where's this IP address coming
from? It's what's got my
That would be a
I think it would be a node IP
for one of the
one of the control plane nodes.
No. Not in the ten zero two range.
No? Okay.
Let's
just have a quick look. I
can do that from get nodes. So Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
No. 10.
10 eighties. Okay. Well, I I I then
don't understand why there is a 10 o.
Oh oh, wait.
No. Didn't
we see that in
on one of the city pods or
what was that? No. I don't believe
so. So there's no IP address. Yeah. I
know. We're we're not using that. We're using
+1 92. It's right.
Weird.
Okay. So
my end sync was telling me this is
in the Cilium configuration.
So I could go to
Yeah. Here.
Yeah. That's right. Yeah. You can double check.
We've configured
yeah. Let's let's do this. Yeah. Yeah. No.
It's not it's not there. Right? So one
thing that you can,
yeah, check once again,
Cilium status.
Yep.
Just double check that it's reporting the IPAM
as healthy, doesn't it?
Yeah. It's it's reporting that two out of
two fifty five are allocated.
Right. So there there should be plenty of
IPs to go about.
Okay. So I Somehow the allocations are not
working.
So the hypothesis right now is that that
IP address is some sort of hungover thing
from the previous
deployment? I mean, we did reuse a cluster.
So I Oh, yeah. That's right. So yeah.
I see I see that that's actually possible
that
we tried to
that that Cilium stored some state, and it's
just trying to reuse that. Yeah. Because we
deleted all the pods, but I'm assuming other
secrets contact map. And we run Cilium command
yeah. Exactly. They they could be they
could be something stored in the on the
machine. So if you run Cilium command once
again, I think there was a a way
to to
start a service preflight.
Let's see.
Clean up the Clean up. Yeah. Yeah. Do
clean up. You might wanna do it on
every
On every pod?
Okay.
Alright. It doesn't work from within a part
of a sling.
If you reboot the machines
that Uh-huh.
Yeah. Fix it.
You know, things are not going to plan,
but this is fun. I'm enjoying
It's it's quite fun, David. Yeah. You're challenging
me, definitely.
So we wanna reboot
every note. Right? Yeah.
What our views are saying.
So a reboot probably gonna take us around
one minute. But just to kinda provide an
idea of what's going on to people that
just joined us and going, what the then
we had a cluster. So we
deployed Cilium
to it
and Yeah. Used the default configuration. We were
following a quick start gate. Unfortunately, that default
configuration did have conflicts with the packets private
network IP address range.
So we abandoned our plan and went to
mini cube, but then we ran into problems
with mini cube because
I am running it in Docker for Mac.
Because, you know, I know well, I should
know better. I didn't know better. And I'm
putting earlier here through an awful lot. We've
come
back to our packet Kubernetes cluster,
and we customized
using the helm command and templated our own
unique Snowflake, you said they have those which
should work with the packet. Private IP for
IPv
for network. Unfortunately,
we think
that
that left some traces of the old configuration
on the machine. So we are now rebooting
them all,
and we should be able to monitor that
coming back when one of the control blend
nodes comes back via get nodes. So this
may just take another moment. Is there anything
I missed? Do you think I covered This
is very good. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, the
the the just to clarify,
David hasn't installed Cilium on Packet
or any other cluster API based setup.
I have not installed Cilium in a packet
or a cluster API based setup yet.
I had been playing with other providers recently,
but not cluster API
and not packet.
So here we go. It's been it's been
a challenge for both of us, and I
think I think we're getting close. I think
we should be able to sort it out
before
before the show ends.
Well, I mean, we can always chalk this
one down as oops and and revisit this
another day once I've once I am more
familiar with cluster API for sure. Yeah.
Definitely. And, you know, it'd be nice to
to to have a little blog post or
guide
on installing Cilium on cluster API and perhaps
Packet or or possibly any other cluster API
provider. I mean, really, I should have done
is configure the cluster my cluster API cluster
with a a VXLAN on the packet side
so that we had free range of our
own
you know, we could do carte blanche for
our IP address
Mhmm. System there. Yeah. But you don't want
to do two two two like, you don't
wanna tunnel over a tunnel. Right?
Because Cilium sets up a VXLAN tunnel itself
as well.
Oh, okay. Right.
So I guess if I had used overlay
I should say. And cluster API. We still
have that config there. Right? So, I mean
Yeah.
It it would have been a simple
Alright.
So has has anything come back? Are we
seeing any
any machines rebooting in packet consult?
Let's take a look.
Well, let's use the band
and see how far then to the reboot
this is.
YubiKey.
Normally,
things would be talking to me by now.
Let's jump back down here where I'm getting
notes.
Oh, there we go. Okay. So that machine
was just the rebate was taking a little
bit longer. That's a kernel. Mhmm.
I'll leave that out of band console running
so we get a good idea when that
control plane is happy.
And that should mean we can start getting
a response to the key, get nodes, and
fingers
crossed, all the machines roughly come up at
the same time.
So yeah. And then there's also one more
option to try if we are not
not seeing good results, but I think we
should be fine. I think I think there's
just some some odd leftovers
from the last
from the first attempt of installing Cilium with
configuration
that wasn't that wasn't correct.
So does Cilium use
custom resources to store state, like endpoints and
stuff? Yeah.
There was It does use custom resources. That's
right.
Yeah. For a few things.
We we will need to check those as
well, but the
it does it
does save some state on the
on on the machine as in inside the
kernel.
When you when you restart Cilium, it basically
doesn't take the network down, right, as most
as most network plug ins for Kubernetes.
Alright. We are back in business. Oh, sweet.
Okay. Cool. Alright. And all of our nodes
and things are back now? They are. They're
all ready.
Oh, that's that's
that's magic. Yeah. That was a good bet.
Alright. Let's go. At least one thing went
our way. Right?
Yeah. We can jump back into the Cilium
one of the Cilium pods.
The
system's
I guess that's
Cilium pods
aren't quite there yet. Oh, in Cilium namespace
now. Right? Oh, yeah. That's right. Okay.
Cilium.
The first one, we want bash. And you
want me to run add
test. Cilium status.
Not quite ready yet.
Oh, no. I've just had the the job.
It would seem
Internet down Cilium agent.
Oh, yeah. Okay. The well, wait.
Can you do describe one of them?
Yeah. Okay. Cool. This seems to be maybe
one of the yeah. I'm not sure what
happened there. So Cilium,
just do this. Yep.
Okay.
So
and
and Cilium dash health.
Status. Yeah.
I think this is looking a little bit
better.
There's still some odd oh, no. There's still
some tender dose. Okay. So if we have
a look at
oh.
I mean, this one local host is so
the problem is going to be connected to
this. Yeah. David, what you do want is
make
you after installing Cilium into cluster, you you
you really want to bring all the pods
into into Cilium management. Right?
So I think it is possible that some
of those
stale entries are due to
due due
to the fact that those pods aren't fully
managed by Cilium yet. So
can we can you just, like, try and
kick some of those pods?
We did just now, but the but some
of those pods came up before Cilium started
up.
Right?
That is, like, one of the challenge of
network migration
and drop out from that pod. And, yeah,
look in Cilium in the cube system namespace.
And, basically,
if you can just do cube cuddle delete
pods and keep system dash dash all.
Never run this in production, anyone. But what
you can do no. What what you can
do, David, is actually just, like, kick some
of these pods first.
I'm more than happy to kick them all.
Nothing bad's gonna happen.
Yeah. We just rebooted the whole thing. Okay.
But the parts would have the containers would
have been stopped and restarted rather than recreated,
wouldn't I? So this actually will proper kick
them.
Potentially. Alright.
I'm not gonna wait for that to come
back. We'll just come in here and we'll
kinda watch that. I'll come back this way.
Yeah.
For twenty seconds, twenty seconds, twenty seconds. We
still got a couple of proxies disappearing.
CoreDNS.
Yeah. I mean, some of them are having
some issues.
Some of them are in the in the
host network namespace,
but,
you know, I don't need to worry about
filtering those out. So, yeah, this this is
looking
like we're getting some of those pods restarting
now. So if you jump back into that
Cilium pod and check
Cilium health status again,
So let me So can do can you
the the Cilium
endpoint list
now?
So what endpoints do we have?
Oh, yep. Oh, it's like that part. Yeah.
Endpoint
list.
So
there's there's
what is that one? Yeah. No. It doesn't
look like we have actually,
yeah. We have a node. Right?
And we don't have any any port endpoints
here.
Alright. So
Where does Cilium store the IP addresses of
all the agents?
Oh, yeah. In Cilium node object. Let's have
a look at those. So if you look
at if you oh, yeah. Well, you can
have a look at here. Node list, yeah,
for example. Yeah. So these these are wrong.
Right?
Yeah. These are wrong. What?
Yeah.
That is that is that is a problem.
And one of them is is fine, but
the the other ones are are old.
So we want to
probably try and clear some of those CRDs.
I think that's,
yeah, that's where it's gone wrong, man. So
if I do get Oh, have a look
have a look at the
yeah. Not CEP. No. They do
Cilium
nodes.
Yeah.
So we just delete all of them. Right?
I think it should be fine. Yeah.
An agent should recreate them, I would imagine.
Yeah.
It's not like a production cluster or anything.
Right? We're kinda we're kinda learning. I think
this is this is this is cool learning
experience by the Seriously, I am learning
a lot about debugging this stuff. Okay. I
have one node come back.
Okay.
I mean, not just the agent parts. Would
that help?
I do get part I mean, if I
just restart
all the
Operators
rather.
It's okay. Do you want me to restart
the operators?
Why not?
I assumed, I guess, incorrectly, that Cilium nodes
would be created by each of the agents.
Would they would they not manage their own
node?
I think it's it's operator, but
from memory.
Again.
Okay. So now we have one Cilium node.
That's brilliant.
I'm gonna delete it. I'm I'm just gonna
Yeah. Let's yeah. Let's delete all all the
Cilium pods. Yeah.
Okay. So now I wanna see the pods
coming back, and I wanna see that Cilium
node list looking really good, and I want
this campaign to work.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, sweet. Okay. Good. Yeah. Okay. And now
back into a
any of the Cilium pods and just double
check
what are we seeing.
Cilium
yeah. And they're, like, Cilium health status
on node list. Just looking good, David. Yeah.
We we're getting to fix this.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh, this is this is this is much
closer. Right? There's there's some
sort of happiness here.
Where are those
oh, wait. Okay. But this this is probably
the That's better. This is good. Yeah. This
is this is at least trying to use
some existing IP addresses and not, like,
non existing ones. Okay.
Okay. Cool.
But there's there's, like, connectivity issue between private
nodes and
public nodes. Right?
So you're saying that the private node public
nodes wouldn't be able to reach
private IPs?
I don't understand. Sorry. So you you said
there are two types of nodes in this
cluster. You said there's
there are
there there are public Every node has a
private IP and a public IP. Oh, oh,
okay. Sorry. I misunderstood that earlier.
Okay. Okay. So I think this is this
is this is probably fine.
And this
is this is definitely better.
And there's no confusing stuff in here that
I can see anymore.
And does this this seems like there's more
entries now?
Yeah.
And
so it's gonna default, namespace default. Yeah. So
you can now see these echo b pods
from the default namespace
with
we we see the Cilium endpoints associated with
So those yeah. Those tests are all actually
running now.
Oh, sweet.
Okay.
And they are some of them are even
succeeding.
They are. Yeah. They're they're getting there. So
the connectivity test now seem to be doing
as we expected.
You you almost have the notes for the
blog post now, David,
which we can review.
So
okay.
Okay. That's that's definitely way better than earlier.
So we'd be brave and deploy the Star
Wars demo? We
can just
oh, look. There's a crash look there. Multi
note headless.
Okay.
Anyway, yeah, we can try the Star Wars
demo. Why not? But if you can you
can just also try, like, keep CQL get
CEP and have a look if there are
any Cilium endpoints just to sort of
understand that.
They're hard. Yeah. Sweet.
And you could, like, basically inspect some of
these, and you can find out some some
of the the information that Cilium stores about
each of the pods and confirm this whole
idea of
port identity.
Yeah.
So what do I what do I have
here? What's important?
Okay. So ignore the managed bit. Alright. So
So
it's just
a
representation
of
Alright. Okay. Of a pod. And there there's
an ID being assigned to it
and a set of labels, and then you
can use these labels to express
policy.
Okay. So let's
I think we have, like, mostly working configuration
then. I think there are few few few
things that that we'll need to to do
some more homework on, but
I think this is
this is pretty good for for a first
time install,
you know,
in the new provider.
Oh, yeah. Definitely. Like I said, this has
been very valuable for me just to get
to kinda learn what things are are doing.
Mhmm.
So if I
I'm gonna deploy the Star Wars thing again
because I'm just Yeah. I'm feeling really brave
now after all of that.
I can't feel any braver than that. Alright.
So what does the Star Wars demo
do? Just a couple of parts.
The
the idea is that there is a
there's a Death Star
thing that has an API,
and you can
destroy the desk star
by using the API.
But you can implement policy that seals
the
the endpoint
that that allows you to destroy the death
star.
And you could override the response, for example.
So it's like a potentially vulnerable service
that you can protect through policy.
Okay. So
quickly scanning this page on the demo then.
It's saying that
any ship labeled
any pods labeled with org equals empire
are allowed to communicate with the desk there.
Yeah.
Means if I run this command
Mhmm.
Oh, no. That's not gonna work
because
core DNS. Oh, no. Core DNS is running
there. Oh, why did that not Oh, great.
Sweet. Okay.
And it's all in default namespace now. Right?
No. It's in keep sis is it no.
It's it's in default. Right? The the Star
Wars demo is in default namespace, David?
Yeah. So I'll just click second to this
part.
Yeah. Let's do that. Go into the x
wing. I always like them.
I'm gonna check if DNS is working then.
So that's our default
s c c cluster local.
No.
But that would be a service IP campaign
game.
But I just wanted to see if it
would resolve. Yeah. I can use Oh, yeah.
Alright. I know. I get you.
I think Now let's look up maybe.
The store.
Can you ping ping your DNS?
Can you can you resolve Google or whatever?
I remember right. The IP address for cluster
DNS is 1000986.
Why have we got oh, yeah. The service
is so called QTNS.
So,
yeah, I can't But it's a service IP.
You can't ping it again.
Can you
yeah. Check check resolve con.
So this is
name server, the same one that we just
tried.
Okay. And if you try a nest lookup
for
Kubernetes
right.
DNS is definitely broken.
Somehow DNS is broken. That's
Alright. Let's
not try and fix. No. No. I think
I think you definitely need to investigate that.
But one thing I'd recommend is that, you
know, try and try and somehow hook Cilium
installation directly into the cluster API
provisioning
phase.
Right? So you you you you can you
could get Cilium installed from the get go,
and no funny business, hopefully.
Well, I think I'll make that my homework
for the next week or so and
really dig into this and make sure that
I can get Cilium working
properly with the cluster API. I think that's
really important,
especially with the power and the features that
Cilium brings to the table is the CNI
implementation. I I really do want us to
work well on packet with the cluster API.
So I will continue to fight the good
fate here, and I get a nice blog
post out, making this easy for people to
consume and use as well. I wanna just
thank you for your time. I know that
was a bit of a slog,
and there was a lot of things thrown
at you there that we kinda had to
try and debug. But you know what? That's
computers. Things don't always work, and you gotta
be prepared for that battle. So I really
appreciate your help and perseverance as we try
to get that working. It was good to
see you, David. Yeah. You too. So I
am thank you very much. For watching. Thanks.
Thanks. Yeah. Thank you for your time, and
we'll definitely do a part two of this
once I I iron out the kinks of
the cluster API implementation, and we'll see what
happens then. So have a great day, everyone,
and thanks again, Julio.